les ménages prévoyant une mutuelle qui
perdure créée en 1854 par le baron
caruhel de saint martin la lmp fêté
jeudi dernier à versailles c'est cent
soixante années d'existence aux origines
la lmp permettait à ses sociétaires de
bénéficier d'un accès gratuit aux soins
puis elle s'est développée en accord
avec l'évolution des besoins sociaux ça
normal qu'elle se soigne et d'avoir les
médicaments première mutuelle à accepter
les femmes comme sociétaire la langue
des signes en 1955 un contrat
d'entreprise avec le site renault de
flins une stratégie qui lui permettra de
passer de 1000 sociétaires en 1945 à
plus de 60 millions dans les années 2000
répondre à la norme solvabilité ii
européenne qui va nous imposer la
solvabilité supplémentaires
l'allemand un grand défi à relever parce
que 1er janvier 2016 qui seront soumis
aux mêmes règles que les grandes
sociétés d'assurances en 2016 les
nouvelles règles législatives
européennes impacteront tous les
organismes d'assurance
un nouveau défi pour la mutuelle
notamment avec les nouvelles règles de
gouvernance